en ligne franchement si c'est un truc
nous et je break machine moi j'étais me
suis toujours dit tu imagines tu vas y
que ta meuf à l'île de la tentation
déjà tu vas castaldi l'île de la
tentation
[Rires]
lui voit le zodiaque arrivé déjà il
attend même pas que la farine sur le sol
vous en perdez pas j'arrive direct
franchement dit la vérité et je pose la
question qui aurait pu craquer sur l'île
de la tentation
baraka cela dit si vous êtes à à 30 ans
évidemment vous auriez 4 idrac est ce
que vous auriez craqué sur les nôtres
c'est sur ces faits pour cinq ans et qui
fait donc vous aurez brennan et je suis
certaine
bilal aurait gras craqué sur l'îlot
boulette j'ai craqué j'ai mangé comme
casey bell avec pato qui moi qui avez
vous vu qu avez-vous entendu pas je les
ai vus en train de manger une boulette
une boulette à l'ani et non mais c'est
vrai mais moi je vous assure ça aurait
été comme les couples mais pénalisant
jamais on euros benneteau était comme
tout le monde comme ça le premier soir
sans ponts sont pas le premier soir le
premier après l'erreur la première heure
dans la vie on les attaquait alors moi
malheureusement je ne bois pas d'alcool
et je me drogue pas alors je vais alors
si jolie de la tentation et au vote mais
qu'il est sur une autre île mais si
c'est un mec que j'aime d'amour non je
vais pas le tromper mais du coup je me
ferais chier là bas et ça m'intéressera
pas et si chez avec un mec dont je m'en
fous oui pourquoi pas toi donc ça peut
pêcher sur lui doit pas fait chaud bon
vous jouez vous tech beaucoup trop
fidèle mais faut pas me faire comme
brendon prendra un espèce de fable et
bâtons droite à leur merci donc c'est
quoi c'est oui ou c'est non c'est non
[Rires]
vous avez remarqué odile et c'est bon
j'ai demandé au premier ministre si vous
avez baissé la verge et c'est nord dont
vous alors je suis sûr que non mais
j'aurais pape et le risque quand même
pas tout elle aurait pu craquer crois
pas que je crois pas que j'espère selon
vous la connaissez bien alors je vais te
dire elle est venue du 23 septembre au
mois et les gens du 23 septembre sont
extrêmement fidèle à l'oc je peux te
dire là bas elle n'a pas dans les rêves
que je fais merci mais j'aurais fait
comme les hamsters genre prix de la
nourriture d'almansa une fois que celles
avec l'or vous dit juste un truc les
deux vous allez rentrer plus tôt merci
maman elle va rentrer bientôt
non mais c'est sûr que si on rentre pas
dans ce jeu là on doit vraiment
s'ennuyer sur cette voie là oui mais non
mais il faut faire un pacte avec son
copain que quoi qu'il arrive quoi qu'il
arrive au niveau du montage démago il
faut alors je vais sur l'autre il cite
[Rires]
jamais soutenu alors qu'elle est où j'ai
vu roger j'ai vu roger que votre nom
soit sassou en train de se trémousser
avec jacqueline pellet d'être assurés
nés avec des vieilles mais on peut faire
dire beaucoup de choses à des images
avec du sous bois
[Musique]
un tuto tu peu embrouillée roger mais
hanouna elle me dit ça on peut dire
faire beaucoup de choses à laisser
tomber tu prends tes valises et tu te
sens pas t'imaginer - est-ce que vous
imaginez moi je vois ma meuf sur le truc
comme à ce voyage alors vous c'est pire
que brandon benhaim alors j'avoue moi je
vois ma meuf qu'au match et je vois la
femelle crapaud le faire j'y vais sur
l'île un carnage mais je prends un
poisson un cabillaud surtout quand même
on est ce qu'on voulait voir la suite
s'annonce qu'avez vous vu qu'ils avaient
vu madame avec deux grandes personnes
voilà non mais où il y en a mais ça
c'est un truc de pat o may cry ah oui le
bateau choix sur l'autre il indiquera qu
il est jaloux par h non il sera créé
avec d'autres
oui c'est un homme filmé alors vous
n'avez repêché assez lucide sont
unanimes en 2018 pouvez-vous dire on
n'avait plus confiance en l'homme et la
nature humaine avec un témoin voilà si
on vous tente beaucoup il faut mais
voilà bombe a tué de leurs mots et vous
êtes group espas tâche on n'est pas là
c'est pas le fait pas
bas les masques pardon beaucoup témoin
temps on m'appelait l'obélix à leurs
amis ou amoureux
merci d'aller à la concorde à 100
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi tu dis ça moi je pense que ça
va être ça dépend il est dans l'état
d'esprit dans lequel on part ouais si on
décide de ne pas s'amuser il se passera
rien si on décide de se lâcher ben alors
généralement c est ce que moi je
prendrais moi je tiendrai moi ma meuf
elle me dit façon d'affaires leader
totale et elle vous dis moi écoute
chérie je voudrais absolument tester la
force de notre amour
ah oui c'est vrai que vraiment on va le
tester tout de suite et enfermé tu sais
faire l'île de la tentation vous avez
confiance en elle moi j'aimerais faire
sans lui même n'avait pas confiance en
vous même
qu'est-ce que vous l'ayez pas dans le
sens que vous êtes sûr de la tromper
donc moi
[Applaudissements]
derrière franchement j'ai beaucoup plus
et moi j'ai confiance en moi et benayoun
qui me connaît très bien
île de la tentation est il de la
tentacule ou n'apportaient rien n'arrive
pas sur vous vous êtes vous êtes
nouvelle dans le groupe des l5 on vous
enlevez votre micro d'accord donc
apparemment il sera quoi tu parle pas
[Applaudissements]